do you find that Mr Depp has proven all
the elements of defamation answer yes
moments after that verdict and Johnny
Depp's victory in his defamation trial
Amber Heard speaks out
the jury says the actor was indeed
defamed by heard awarding him 15 million
dollars in both punitive and
compensatory damages has Mr Depp proven
by a greater weight of the evidence
that question the statement was made or
published by Ms heard answer yes
following the decision Amber shares this
statement the disappointment I feel
today is beyond words I'm heartbroken
that the mountain of evidence still was
not enough to stand up to the
disproportionate power influence and
sway of my ex-husband I'm even more
disappointed with what this verdict
means for other women it is a setback it
sets back the clock to a time when a
woman who spoke up and spoke out could
be publicly shamed and humiliated it
sets back the idea that violence against
women is to be taken seriously Mr four
person is this the verdict of the jury
all right is it unanimous
thank you sir as Amber tells it this
trial was also about rights promised by
the First Amendment she goes on to say I
believe Johnny's attorneys succeeded in
getting the jury to overlook the key
issue of freedom of speech and ignore
evidence that was so conclusive that we
won in the UK I'm sad I lost this case
but I am sadder still that I seem to
have lost a right I thought I had as an
American to speak freely and openly it
should be noted Amber also received a
verdict in her countersuit against Depp
the jury awarded her two million dollars
in compensatory damages question the
statement was seen by someone other than
misheard answer yes now many celebrities
are taking a social media with their
reactions including Depp's attorney in
his divorce from heard Laura wasser who
writes Gotta Love a jury Megan McCain
tweets hashtag me too is dead meanwhile
Ashley Benson shares this pick of depth
to Instagram writing in the caption yes
alongside black themed are emojis